[Music]
so ken this is an interesting and
distressing part of our world today
we did at ramsey a couple of years ago
the largest
by far
airtight
research
the largest study
of millionaires in north america in the
united states of america ever done
all the details where do they come from
what do they think about did they
inherit their money what are their
careers what's their marital status
what's their race creed color whatever
everything we could figure out and
trying to find a and trying to figure
out okay what does it take
to become a millionaire
in america today a millionaire is a
million dollar net worth for those of
you who don't know it's not a
billionaire
a billion is a thousand million it's a
lot more
if you have
three thousand dollars you're closer to
being a millionaire than a millionaire
is to being a billionaire
as an example so it's not it's not
private jets and seven cars
okay that's not a millionaire a million
dollar net worth is not that much
it but it is more than most people have
there's about uh 17 million millionaires
in america and that's what you own minus
what you owe
equals your net worth your assets minus
your liabilities is your net worth
so if you have no debt and you have a
million dollars in your 401k you're a
millionaire okay that's simple that kind
of a thing all right so we post on
instagram
yesterday
and this is what is societally
distressing
that from this study
not a feeling that we have
we didn't ask your broke brother-in-law
his opinion
we ask real millionaires ten freaking
thousand of them
who they are where they come from
and one of the many
conclusions we drew from this was the
top 10
career fields that we found
according to frequency within the study
so who what career field did we find
most often
second most often and so on the most
often we found was engineer
the second was an accountant or cpa the
third was teacher
the fourth was management
the fifth was attorney
so not even making the top five is
medical doctor
by the way there were six
number six
but they were not even in the top five
and we post that on there
and instagram and facebook
proves once again
that humanity is full of morons
i mean if you read comments after
articles or comments after posts like
this you understand why some species
ether young people are dumber than a
rock out there oh yeah a lot of
mouthpieces some of you listening are
dumber than a rock
i mean i never heard this is ridiculous
so here's the thing okay we've done
detailed scientific research that proved
that the sun is hot
and we post it yeah on instagram the sun
is hot some of you morons will disagree
with that yeah
just because you think you have a right
to
and you should really stop before you
post something because it makes you look
stupid
okay was that unclear well probably i i
felt like you could have had a little
bit more enthusiasm for what you were
saying i felt like it felt like it lost
a little fervor no i think you're
absolutely right this is data and you
know what's funny is like people they
want to argue like we're duping people
yeah like what we're just saying yeah
right dave ramsey teachers aren't really
making that kind of money not where i
live i'm a teacher teachers can't be
millionaires no way teachers can be
millionaires no teachers should be on
there where are the nurses where are the
nurses well you nurses get your butt in
gear and i guess you'll make the dead
gum list oh my gosh well what they're
missing what these brilliant mouth
breathers have forgotten in this post is
that it has nothing to do with the
salary has everything to do with the way
they live
now engineers certainly can make way
more money than a teacher but it is they
have lived on less than they make they
have saved they have invested they've
walked the clear path the baby steps
their baby steps millionaires and that's
what they're missing here they think oh
i know what a teacher salary is you guys
are just making this stuff up
as if you're into cleveland i'll tell
you what all five students share in
common all five professions are systems
people that's right they all work
systems yeah teachers work
a teaching plan they have a lesson plan
yeah they work a system and they they if
they somebody gives them a lesson plan
they don't go make up their own yep they
they follow the lesson plan and
engineers they don't make up their own
thing the bridge would fall that's
correct they have to follow the system
they have to follow the processes
attorneys have to follow a process
called the law you know you don't get to
make it up you have to actually adhere
to a process all of these people adhere
to processes for a living and they take
that same part of their personality and
they apply it to their money and voila
they become a millionaire so what is the
data on teacher income well right now
the median income in the united states
is 60 thousand dollars so now before
some of you folks start firing shots at
me on that i said median you know what a
medium is anybody know if you've been in
a good teacher's class you would have
known it's your law of averages you just
run your averages so there's no average
is different than median yeah i know but
i'm just saying if you if you look at
across the board of what the median
salary is for a teacher it's 60. now
that means in some districts in the
united states like for instance i got a
friend who's teaching high school in new
york
upstate new york he's making over six
figures so this is across the board you
look at the median and now we go okay uh
this is what we're looking at in the
united states but again it is about how
they live on less than they make it's
not this study wasn't pointing to how
much they make it was how much they keep
and by the way there is one other
correlation between all of these
millionaires they love their work yeah
that's an 80 percentile range 80 percent
they so let me help you with this if you
invest from age 30 to age 65
in a decent growth stock mutual fund 15
of 60 000
you'll have 4.8 million dollars yeah
there it is now you can also
fire off a bunch of comments about that
but that was math you don't really get
to negotiate with math yeah that's how
math works it just is or it isn't that's
right you don't get to make up your own
version that's not enough and so if
that's so if one if you only are
one-fifth as good as we teach right
i mean five million bucks 4.8 million
right okay you would still have one
million dollars right and from age 30 to
age 65
but dave that's all too clear cut and
simple for the keyboard warriors
there's got to be more complexity they
got to tear it apart it's got to be a
game
and that's unfortunate that's the sad
part the sad part is is that we have a
portion of our culture now who rather
than fix their life
and address the person in the mirror's
deficits instead wants a narrative that
declares them a victim there it is
that can't possibly be true dave because
if that's true i could do it
if you're if your study was accurate
what do you know about my study you just
you just
if your mouth was shut you wouldn't be
making noise oh my god but dave they're
mouth breathers so the mouth can't be
shut
seriously people
you really should abstain from the
comments section reading them or
commenting on them oh my gosh there's a
reason
that you and i both get so visibly
frustrated
with people that have a victim narrative
and insist on spreading their victim
narrative
we know
from
having worked with thousands and even
millions of people
that most anyone that follows a proven
process can go get a great job can get
out of debt and build wealth can have a
good marriage we know that people that
are that choose to control their
behavior in spite of the negative
influences from the outside in spite of
bad things having happened to them and
we all have challenges but in spite of
the challenges we know that people can
create for themselves carve out for
themselves a good life if they bother
when someone posts a negative narrative
that says oh teachers can't do it then
someone believes that or you're in an
echo chamber with a bunch of people that
says teachers can't do it then god help
us teachers believe they can't do it
and we know that that's not true and
you've then limited someone's belief in
someone's future and you've brought harm
to them and we love people and we love
people that so much we want them to win
and anything that keeps them from
winning including you debbie downers out
there we're you're going to be at the
tip of our sharp tongue yeah yeah i
agree with that and let me just say this
as much as we will take shots at people
that that are constantly negative and
cynical
i i do even you could do it if you'd
quit doing that i feel sadness over that
because because you've bought in some
form or fashion a false narrative you
have had some bad stuff happen to you
maybe somebody did something maybe you
made a mistake and you did something
dumb that doesn't disqualify you from
being a victor i've never read a
biography in my life and i've read a lot
of them uh where the the story the
person in the story that we're reading
about always did everything right had no
hardship had no self-inflicted wounds
had no disadvantages so i absolutely
agree with you we get fired up on this
because we're in the business of hope
we're in the business of giving people
hope that they can be who they're
supposed to be they can do what they
want to do um and yeah it really makes
me angry when people just go nah that's
all a pipe dream and uh yeah it
irritates us and we live in a world
today where people really are influenced
shockingly by the comment in the comment
section by the negative yeah and yeah
that's why negative fires up the
negative the negative good grief here's
my deal if you really believe that
then why do you feel like you got to
share that with everybody else i mean
you you have the right to believe and
say and i will always fight for liberty
to say and be negative and uh your
that's what you want to be great but
don't bring it around the rest of us
yeah old country's saying if you ain't
got something nice to say don't you say
nothing at all
i mean life is too short pastor friend
of mine used to say if it's not helpful
hopeful or promotes healing you don't
need to say it that's good
yeah it's not helpful hopeful or
promotes healing yeah you don't need to
say it yeah
and um i couldn't i could take it to
that advice occasionally too i just
called a whole bunch of people stupid so
but i think that might have been healing
though i think it was it was it was a
little therapeutic for both yeah me and
you were healed by it
yeah yeah but i will say this i think
it's fair to say that someone is stupid
or unintelligent when they argue data
yeah but by the way those are the same
people that go science over here but
we're going to argue something we don't
like and you've heard this before you
don't like it that's right we hear what
we want to hear we see what we go
chamber city man it's just people man
man oh man